à voir ses murs immaculés ses colonnes
néoclassiques il est difficile de croire
qu'il y a seulement 4 ans la villa
viardo était à l'état de ruine un long
voyage qui a connu sa conclusion le 16
septembre avec son inauguration c'est un
moment de de forte émotion c'est un rêve
de 23 ans 23 ans de combat pour le
rendre réel et quand il est là devant
mes yeux vous pouvez
imaginer l'émotion la la reconnaissance
la gratitude vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui
ont cru à notre projet pour y parvenir
Bougival qui labrite à signé un bail à
longue durée AC le propriétaire la ville
de la selle saclou budget des travaux
5,8 million d'euros un chantier réussi
grâce au concours du département des
ivelines de la région île-defance de
laadc la Fondation du Patrimoine total
et une souscription il y a dans les
ivelines un patrimoine d'intérêt
régional que je veux on redécouvre je
veux des une région Île-de-France qui
soit à la fois créative mais aussi
enracinée qu'on redécouvre ces hommes et
particulièrement ces femmes qui ont fait
les arts et l'histoire des arts de
l'Île-de-France la contatrice Pauline
viardo et son mari achètent le site en
1874 ils en font un lieu de foisonnement
intellectuel un passé que la rénovation
va faire revenir en intégrant la villa
au centre européen de musique l'esprit
euh de des lieux l'esprit des lieux
c'est quand Pauline viardau recevait ses
amis écrivains ses amis musiciens euh
ceux qui dans l'Europe du 19e siècle euh
étaient les plus adulé euh et c'est ce
qu'on souhaite c'est vraiment que euh
cette villelà à travers des concerts des
mastercl internationales à travers des
conférences euh
soit un lieu dans lequel la culture
européenne est un
sens avec cette rénovation la ville
aviardo entre un peu plus dans le
patrimoine ivelinois elle a été inscrite
au titre des Monuments Historiques en